y comenzamos una nueva emisión de
reporteros en france 24 gracias por
estar con nosotros
afganistán comenzó unas históricas
negociaciones de paz en doha qatar
alrededor de la mesa están sentados
representantes del grupo talibán y
representantes del gobierno afgano el
objetivo es poner fin a un conflicto que
lleva 19 años desde que el talibán fue
expulsado del poder por la coalición
internacional liderada por eeuu para
aceptar el principio de las
conversaciones con el gobierno afgano
el talibán exigió la liberación de 5000
de sus combatientes encarcelados entre
ellos 400 fueron considerados los más
peligrosos y radicales la exigencia de
liberación incondicional de estos
combatientes a la que el gobierno afgano
accedió despertó la indignación de gran
parte de la población que se encuentra
dividida entre la esperanza de que se
logre la paz y el temor de que la
situación empeore mientras la violencia
continua sobre el terreno nos acompaña
así igual a uno de los autores de este
reportaje él tuvo acceso a los talibanes
y le preguntó qué tan difícil
puede acceder a las personas que
conforman este grupo
cuantifica el bueno es muy difícil para
un extranjero en afganistán tener acceso
a áreas controladas por los talibanes lo
que hicimos para este reportaje fue a
través de un periodista local quien fue
nuestro mediador logramos ponernos en
contacto con unos ancianos de una aldea
en la provincia oriental de nangarhar y
son provence of land rober en desfiles
de ver sexta leva en esta aldea vi a
seis ex combatientes talibanes quienes
habían salido de prisión presenta su
waterboxx ventoux después de mí
lo que hicimos fue ir a esta aldea
encontrarnos con los ancianos y ellos
nos permitieron grabar a uno de los
combatientes talibanes en la aldea
lo sorprendente para nosotros fue lo
abiertos que fueron estos combatientes
talibanes comunicándose con nosotros
hablaron abiertamente de su ideología y
de los diálogos sobre el futuro de
afganistán
nos dieron una verdadera mirada en sus
vidas
en el aire
invitados entonces a ver el siguiente
reportaje
[Música]
ahmad abad cala un pueblo situado en las
montañas del este de afganistán al mas
muslim fue liberado de prisión hace
cinco meses después de pasar cuatro años
en la cárcel este ex combatiente talibán
cambió sus armas por esa manguera
h de mal tiempo aquí hay naranjas allá
detrás a julius y al lado hay guayabos
yo me ocuparé del jardín cuido las
plantas y pasó tiempo con mis hijos no
tengo otras actividades no tengo un
trabajo no tengo un negocio
almas muslim combatió durante 15 años
contra el ejército afgano y las fuerzas
extranjeras pásame un poco de agua sus
hijos apenas conocían a su padre a
menudo ausente
mira lo mala
estaba en prisión cuando me enteré de
que mi esposa había dado a luz a una
niña
cuando regrese ella no se quiso acercar
a mí no nos reconocimos
nunca me arrepentí de unirme al
movimiento talibán salí de la cárcel
gracias a los esfuerzos de nuestros
líderes el gobierno no hizo nada por
nosotros
sigo en contacto con nuestros líderes
talibán y nos dijeron que pasemos tiempo
con nuestras familias por el momento no
sale mucho por miedo dice a los
combatientes del autodenominado grupo
estado islámico
la organización que opera en la región
desde 2015 ha sufrido sin embargo
grandes pérdidas como consecuencia de
los ataques de los talibán de los
estadounidenses y de las fuerzas
gubernamentales para este batallón del
ejército afgano los talibanes siguen
siendo el enemigo número uno
el mayor shirzad y sus hombres fueron
solicitados como refuerzos una patrulla
fue buscada en un distrito vecino
verbos y rafa extranjeras
[Música]
el comandante shifter sólo tiene 21 años
sólo han pasado seis meses desde que se
unió al ejército
y actualmente una lucha entre los
talibán y la policía extremadamente
tensa ha colocado minas personales lo
que hace muy difícil moverse por esta
zona
[Aplausos]
la sola nada se ve a favor está la
guerra continuará hasta que haya un
acuerdo de paz
los talibanes no dejarán de luchar
porque eso es lo que los pone en una
posición de fuerza de las negociaciones
lastra significa vale
lucharán hasta que consiguen todo lo que
necesita o las galas araure
los talibán controlaría no tendrían
influencia sobre más del 60% del
territorio afgano hoy al más muslim
tiene una cita a pocos metros de su casa
con estos hombres son sus antiguos
compañeros de armas que como él han sido
amnistiados
a un lado de actuar
como una tumba
todos aquí se ven a sí mismos como
combatientes en libertad condicional
como fue la prisión para ti tuviste
algún problema
ahora tengo problemas psicológicos de
hecho mi salud se deterioró en la
prisión porque los soldados me
torturaron para mí fue lo mismo y ahora
estoy estresado porque no puedo
encontrar un trabajo
y experiencia en la prisión fortaleció
mi creencia en el islam solía luchar con
un rifle ahora estoy listo para usar
bombas para matar a los enemigos si es
necesario fui testigo en prisión de la
tiranía del gobierno afgano que actuaba
bajo las órdenes de las fuerzas
estadounidenses nuestro emir nos ordenó
llevar una vida normal por el momento si
la ley islámica no se aplica y nuestro
emir no los ordena tomaremos de nuevo
las armas contra el gobierno afgano
hemos estado luchando por la
introducción de la ley sharia durante 20
años sacrificando nuestras vidas y
propiedades
nos opondremos al comportamiento de las
mujeres que sean contrarios a las
enseñanzas del islam en la vida de un
hombre la mitad de sus derechos
pertenecen a su esposa el uso del velo
es obligatorio para las mujeres
musulmanas si una mujer quiere dirigir
un hotel u otro negocio no estará en
primera línea sino que tendrá que
subcontratar a través de un pariente
varón a la mujer no se le permite llevar
una tienda ella misma
y docenas de prisioneros talibán
liberados como ellos para facilitar las
negociaciones de paz ya han vuelto a
tomar las armas según fuentes de
seguridad
[Música]
kabul sus calles comerciales su
diversidad la capital se transformó
desde la caída de los talibán en 2001 en
algunos barrios como este la vida
moderna se impuso y las mujeres como
rayana son modelos de emancipación a la
edad de 25 años o planea convertirse en
la voz de las víctimas del conflicto
afgano
los miembros de nuestra red son
familiares de víctimas civiles algunos
aquí han perdido a un ser querido muerto
en ataques en explosiones cometidas por
el autodenominado estado islámico o los
talibanes o por fuerzas gubernamentales
o extranjeras
host cajas más puros y sus hijas
queremos un representante de las
víctimas de la guerra en el proceso de
paz
porque los que se sientan a la mesa de
negociaciones nunca sufrieron en carne
propia la pérdida de un ser querido en
la guerra
creo que deberíamos organizar una
manifestación para que la gente hable de
nosotros
sí sí tenemos que hacerlo
en la calle podríamos convertirnos en
blanco de ataques
recibimos amenazas regularmente
recientemente por ejemplo un prisionero
talibán que fue amnistiado amenazó a uno
de nuestros miembros
[Música]
hola está todo bien
mustafa trae el menú entre las personas
olvidadas en el proceso de paz están las
mujeres como mina reza que disfruta su
libertad sin esconderse
estamos muy preocupados por este proceso
de paz hemos estado luchando por
nuestros derechos durante 20 años dicen
que la paz está llegando
pero qué clase de paz es esta
está todo listo pero el fuego se apagó
como su vejez
mina risa abrió este café hace tres años
cuando oímos que el talibán quiere hacer
la paz con nosotros no creo que eso sea
cierto lucharon durante años y por sus
ideas si crees que van a pararse delante
de mí y aceptarme como soy ahora
piénsalo de nuevo por eso estoy muy
asustada hemos librado tantas batallas
en los últimos 20 años para lograr un
cambio en afganistán cuando vengan que
pasara podré caminar libremente trabajar
estudiar usar mi vestido favorito como
lo hago hoy pueden realmente estar de
acuerdo con eso no lo creo
las paredes de kabul llevan las marcas
de 40 años de virtual
detrás de cada cara se esconde una
historia terrible
trajina comparte la suya tanto como
puede perdió a su hermana hace dos años
a ti fa fue asesinada a los 14 años con
una bala en el corazón disparada por un
policía estaba frente a su escuela
cuando una manifestación política se
salió de control
mi madre lavó el cuerpo de mi hermana
pequeña lloró y gritó mientras la lavaba
como siempre la peinaba en casa me puso
un peine en la mano y me dijo no puedes
lavarlo así que ven y peina la
cuando estaba cepillando el pelo se veía
tan tranquila no podía sentir ninguna
vida en su cuerpo no quería aceptarlo
cuando le besé la frente estaba tan fría
en primer lugar quisiera extender un
saludo a todas las familias de las
víctimas de la guerra en afganistán el
talibán y el gobierno están hablando
entre ellos pero solo puede haber paz si
hay justicia todos estos criminales
deberían ser llevados ante la justicia
no digo que los prisioneros liberados
deban ser asesinados sino que deben
pedir perdón
[Música]
cada semana arraiján a visita la tumba
de su hermana
a ti fa está enterrada en la cima de
esta colina
la colina de los mártires
las personas enterradas aquí son
principalmente víctimas del talibán y
del estado islámico
cada vez que vengo a la tumba de mi
hermana siento su fuerza mi corazón es
más fuerte gracias a ella siento que
ella está aquí siento que me escucha hoy
quiero contarle el progreso que hemos
logrado con el comité decirle que todo
está en marcha que vamos a tratar de
tener un papel en estas negociaciones de
paz
me imagino que un día este cementerio se
convertirá en una tierra verde
cultivo veremos flores en todas partes
organizan se desarrollará y la paz
llegará tendremos una vida normal
ya no tendremos miedo en las calles
tenemos libres seguiremos estudiando
todos avanzaremos
[Música]
más que nunca antes en 40 años la paz en
afganistán parece estar al alcance de la
mano
pero aún así podría requerir muchos
sacrificios
[Música]
del pueblo afgana
regresamos con sí igual a él es uno de
los autores de reportaje que ustedes
acaban de ver y le preguntó qué tan
alejadas son las demandas del grupo
talibán de lo que el gobierno está
dispuesto a hacer como vimos en el
reportaje algunos están dispuestos
incluso a volver a las armas
de acuerdo a fuentes de seguridad en
afganistán docenas de talibanes han
regresado al campo de batalla en deming
bisel fortes
clic de paul y de discal es la principal
razón para volver a la guerra de la
pobreza que enfrentan si ven las aldeas
o las zonas a las que pertenecen son
áreas pobres alejadas y sin ninguna
actividad económica
por otra parte el gobierno no ha
brindado ningún programa de
rehabilitación para estos combatientes y
sexta levanto fighters
andrésol se acuesten también se
cuestiona la transparencia del programa
de liberación de prisioneros nos
reunimos con la representante de la
comisión independiente de derechos
humanos de afganistán
shahar sad akbar y esto fue lo que nos
dijo a veces boxes etc
todo factor post site el hecho de que se
niegue a compartir información pública
con el público genera muchas preguntas
sobre estas personas oa guardiola
waterhouse donde estaban retenidos y por
qué estaban retenidos cuáles eran los
cargos alguno tenía cargos de crímenes
contra la humanidad o crímenes de guerra
el mensaje que nos envían es que la
gente no merece saber la verdad lo cual
es un mensaje terrible para un proceso
nacional importante
con respecto a los lugares donde usted
estuvo hay algo positivo en el legado
dejado por eeuu
hay una preocupación entre las
delegaciones que están reunidas en doha
en este momento sin duda en king right
now is how to sleep in style como
reconciliarse porque ambas partes
representan diferentes aspectos de la
sociedad afgana of the top con sus haití
de tales bandas de dejado los talibanes
tienen una visión islámica
ultraconservadora para el futuro de
afganistán y el gobierno quiere un
sistema democrático mejor existe en
afganistán su votos de disco entre su la
xli hartuko por eso ambos grupos
negociadores deben comprometerse insular
tú compro más valor
wanderers compró por ahora el gobierno
ha sido el más comprometido han liberado
cinco mil prisioneros talibanes y han
perdido la ventaja sobre ellos stop the
bridge
on the taliban un dirigente talibán la
ventaja de los talibanes sigue siendo la
violencia y no han renunciado a ellas
deja 90 pjak software nado de vermeer
kurtley beale luken con el gobierno
espera más compromiso por parte de los
talibanes lo cual se ve difícil porque
los alemanes tienen ventaja en las
negociaciones
el club secreta le van a aparecer en dos
negociaciones bueno gracias a seif alá
por este reportaje que ustedes acá van a
ver y recuerda que pueden ingresar a
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
para ver esta emisión y las anteriores
hasta la próxima semana
[Música]